all right
here we are yet again it's Thursday it's
one o'clock I am Nick Gillespie with
reason and here is Zach weismueller my
reason associate and colleague super
video producer we are joined today by
Taylor Lorenz of the Washington Post and
uh we're going to be joined later by uh
coin centers Peter Van falkenberg we're
going to be talking about Tick Tock
bands about the restrict act and uh the
restrict act and basically moral panics
uh Congressional pants wedding not
simply because they're so old but
because they're worried that Tick Tock
is undermining the very possibility of
uh of America going into the future
Taylor Lorenz thanks for joining us
yeah thanks for having me all right so
what we're gonna do we're gonna uh talk
uh first let's uh Zach let's play that
clip from Kathy Rogers McMorris who I uh
the congresswoman from uh Washington
State who uh maybe a decade ago was
actually seen as an incredibly Pro
technology she was part of a new wave of
Republicans who were embracing the
internet and and all that I promise uh
let's run this clip real quick trust
Tick Tock will ever Embrace American
values values for Freedom human rights
and innovation
Tick Tock has repeatedly chosen the path
for more control more surveillance and
more manipulation
your platform should be banned
all right well you know it's nice to uh
you know see congress not mince words
and the restrict Act is uh actually kind
of open and it wants to restrict the
ability of businesses and individuals to
actually speak and express themselves
and just to get on with their lives uh
Taylor before we get to talking about
the restrict act and we have a couple of
other Great Clips uh from the the recent
Tick Tock hearings that you covered uh
extensively
um let's start by talking about tick
tock tick tock has what like about a
billion users worldwide or something
like that it's got 150 million Americans
how are these people so deluded what are
what are they getting out of using Tick
Tock because you know and again just to
emphasize we talked on a recent
interview podcast in 2019 What drew me
to your work was that you were almost
alone among Tech reporters and saying
you know what like a lot of these social
media platforms especially something
like Tick Tock you know what they're
kind of good they're allowing young
people marginal people individuals to
express themselves in a way that wasn't
available so you know flesh that out a
little bit why is Tick Tock possible uh
why is Tick Tock popular yeah well Tick
Tock is completely unique it's it's very
different than the way American Social
platforms are structured
um specifically you know us-based social
platforms are primarily based on this
follower notion like you know we're all
used to it you sign you've downloaded
app and then you as the user have the
burden of having to like you know find
people subscribe to them follow them
you're getting all their content
um and this is kind of just a heavy
burden on the user it's annoying tick
tock's Innovation is this
algorithmically driven for you algorithm
so for you feed so instead you could be
on Tick Tock you could have no followers
and you could follow no one you could
post a video and it could reach Millions
if people find it engaging basically
what Tick Tock does is it takes every
video and it sort of tests it with
larger and larger audiences and so it
really gives people that wouldn't have
previously have had a platform because
they haven't spent years building up a
subscriber base for instance
um it resets that whole power Dynamic
where they're now anybody can have a
voice and kind of go viral assuming they
post something engaging enough
um and you know that's something that we
don't have here I mean we know like on
Twitter for instance right it's like all
these Legacy people with hundreds of
thousands of followers someone joins
Twitter they have no followers they have
basically no voice so
you know in that way yeah well and um
how much at least in the earlier days uh
Tick Tock also seemed to have it was
less about politics uh and it seemed to
be more about kind of expressing either
who you are what you like to do or you
know I mean to call it cultural is is
not quite right because all social media
are all media is is cultural but it
seemed to be almost a respite from uh
redoubt from the politics that we were
seeing on Facebook and on Twitter in
particular
yeah well
home for activism but it fills itself as
an entertainment platform that's the way
it talks about itself right it considers
itself competing with Netflix and Hulu
um so it's showing engaging content but
it's not
it's not necessarily like you know
it's becoming this place for politics
the way that like Facebook has and
Twitter has because they've courted
those political people tick tock
absolutely does not court that type of
stuff I think because of the
geopolitical stuff uh in fact yeah you
said that uh it's completely unique
because of this for you algorithm and
that's something we heard a lot about in
the Congressional testimony that this
unique algorithm is is the problem
because it's uniquely addictive and
damaging to uh children in particular uh
because of the artificial intelligence
behind it is not geared to keep uh
people safe I guess so have you seen any
evidence that tick tock's algorithm is
uniquely damaging as compared to YouTube
or Twitter or Facebook and so forth no I
mean I was just dying in that testimony
because we have seen time and time again
Facebook Twitter you know YouTube
YouTube
amplify you know horrible extremist
content through algorithmically driven
feeds and recommendation systems that
harm has been proven that harm has not
been as proven on Tick Tock
um Tick Tock has very strict moderation
guidelines for sure
um you know just the way that Facebook
does obviously there's things that you
can't upload
um but you know
the problems that they when they're
talking about Tick Tock yes algorithmic
feeds have problems those are those are
problems across like all algorithmic
feeds that's the problem with optimizing
for engagement that comes with certain
problems those problems also appear on
Twitter Instagram and YouTube in fact as
we've seen you know those companies have
been around longer but we've seen a lot
more damaging stuff come off out of
those companies which is why they're so
eager to make Tick Tock The Boogeyman
uh how much of it is also I mean uh can
you explain the ownership structure of
tick tock particularly in the United
States because you know it I mean all
forms of New Media you know whether it's
you know these These are old examples
but they're relevant you know whether
it's the novel whether it's the radio
whether it's movies whether it's rock
and roll or video games all new forms of
media as they gain an audience scare the
out of you know the the the adults
in the room right
um but tick tock not only is new and is
growing you know very rapidly
um but it is also you know somehow you
know a direct pipeline into the Chinese
Communist Party how much what is the
ownership structure of of uh Tick Tock
and how is that influencing the
discussion about it yeah so so Tick Tock
is a company that's owned by bite dance
so what happened is musically was an
American company right
um musically took off was incredibly
popular once again everyone in Tech
ignored it and shot on it and all of
that
um bite dance cloned that up and found
success um cloning that up called doyin
in China which is basically Chinese Tick
Tock
um and then they bought musically and
musically became Tick Tock so it's just
very funny to me because where were all
these concerns like you had all these
concerns about Tick Tock now you let it
sell you let musically was an American
company that they allowed that sale to
happen to a Chinese company like just
four or five years ago
um but so musically eventually became
Tick Tock um and Tick Tock is owned by
bite dance which is a Chinese
Corporation
um by dance is based in China tick tock
I actually don't know where Tick Tock is
based uh the CEO is in Singapore
um so he's there and then uh it's the
U.S it's sort of run regionally around
the world so there's the American Market
um with an American CEO there we have
not I mean look I think all journalists
we would love to find a Smoking Gun that
links Tick Tock somehow to the Chinese
Communist party I think there's
certainly viable questions to ask about
ownership structure and the details of
that but you know it was ridiculous to
see them asking the CEO if he was part
of the Chinese Communist party and he
had to explain he's not even Chinese
let's run the uh the Great Clip that you
have Zach from uh buddy Carter
uh Congressman this committee including
myself who believed that the Chinese
Communist party is engaged in
psychological warfare
through Tick Tock to deliberately
influence U.S children
you know you see behind me if you look
behind me Mr you see some of the
challenges that we've seen on Tick Tock
you know about them you know about the
milk crate you know about the uh about
the Blackout Challenge you know about
the uh NyQuil chicken challenge the
Benadryl challenge do they have these
same things over there
do they have these kind of challenges in
China Congressman I'm really glad you
asked this question do they yes or no
I'm not sure because come on now you're
not sure I really I'm not sure
yeah let's uh you know first let's uh
just pause however the whole NyQuil
chicken uh craze which you know has I
guess now you know Tide Pods are
yesterday you know they're like uh
brussels sprouts with bacon and olive
oil
um but yeah talk about yeah let me just
say every single one of those things
that he's cited is face is is fake it's
a lie it is not true if that is a lot
like that is just is just flat out made
up nonsense I cannot express this strong
enough none of these challenges exist on
Tick Tock or have ever existed on Tick
Tock the milk crate challenge which he's
talking about is from a 2016-2017
Facebook challenge the Blackout
Challenge that is a thing that 82
children died of between the eight years
of 1995 and 2007 or eight way before
Tick Tock the Benadryl thing Good
Morning America did an entire segment on
that in 2002 because it was such a
problem among teens this is not these
are not tick tock
challenges and
it's just so ridiculous to say they're
doing psychological warfare with these
things that don't exist that are that
are not
yeah so it's it's it's you know doubly
stupid right because these are not
Tick-Tock challenges uh in any
meaningful way and these are the kinds
of moral panics that happen all the time
my favorite in this whole scheme of
things going back uh more you know a
couple decades was the jenkum challenge
which was uh I mean it was made up but
it was the idea that uh you know
teenagers were fermenting their own
urine and excrement and huffing it and
it you know a bunch of not surprisingly
uh police departments Sheriff
departments in Florida sent out
advisories and it's you know it's a joke
I mean it's like smoking banana strings
or something like that in order to get
high uh back in the 60s so it's it's
wrong that way but then the
psychological component this seems to be
a very Lively fear about Tick Tock
because it's being directed by the
Chinese government and you know what
they're doing is they're having our kids
you know kill themselves on milk crates
or choking each other or eating you know
everything from chicken to Impossible
Burger to whatever soaked in Nyquil
while Chinese kids on the equivalent of
tick tock and Tick Tock does not exist
in China in the same form but they're
doing you know they have calculus
challenges how much of this is just a
recurring fear uh that gets expressed
through New Media Taylor yeah
yeah I wrote a big feature about this
stuff for the Atlantic years ago before
Tick Tock even launched and it's so
relevant because I used to I spent years
debunking all this stuff related to
YouTube
um and even Facebook right the Momo
challenge was uh we're convinced that
this thing was you know children were
killing themselves because of this
WhatsApp message
um these are all related to like playing
into parents worst fears right parents
see their kids spending new time on an
app they don't understand this new
technology some police officer says you
know oh that's actually that could kill
them I mean SNL famously did a skit God
like nine or ten years ago mocking all
of these you know fake teen moral Panic
news stories but I think in the age of
you know misinformation and all this
stuff spreading all over it's just it's
easy it's this stuff is even it's just
it's taken hold in a way that it never
has before and I think that's because
Tick Tock you can play into that China
fear right it has that extra layer of
like you know the Chinese
yeah what do you make of that fear
though of what uh buddy Carter laid out
there that
on doya and none of this is allowed uh
and so therefore there's something
nefarious going on here because the the
Chinese holding company that owns or the
Chinese uh parent company that owns both
of these is allowing the algorithm to
run loose over here but you know quote
unquote protecting the children over
there it does that raise any red flags
for you
if those things were happening okay
maybe he would have a point none of
those things are happening it's nonsense
the NyQuil chicken thing is a is a meme
from 4chan and and it was on Reddit and
Twitter it's a joke it's not a it's not
even something that's viral none of
these things are actual viral things
like no influencers are doing that it's
like the tide pod thing right where like
maybe once it's viral enough people do
it ironically and actually based off
this Congressional testimony searches
for all of these terms went up once
again they perpetuate this stuff but it
it doesn't exist here you can't say oh
well you know you're all this stuff is
existing here but not in China no it
doesn't exist here either we have no
idea what's happening in China frankly
but we we know that it's not happening
here so the whole outrage over it what
are you outraged it doesn't exist
uh Zach you wanna you've got another
clip right we should uh look at from the
hearings yes I've got a clip from Dan
Crenshaw who I think uh represent from
Texas who I think summarizes the
the fears uh more succinctly than anyone
else in this testimony so I'd just like
to play his summary here and get
everyone's reaction to that
Tick Tock is able to collect massive
amounts of personal data we all know
that that means it could if it desired
to use this data to influence narratives
and Trends create misinformation
campaigns encourage self-destructive
Behavior purposefully allow drug cartels
to communicate freely and organize human
and drug trafficking and to be fair all
social media companies could do that
here's the difference it is only Tick
Tock that is controlled by the Chinese
Communist party all these other social
media companies are not I want to say
this to all the teenagers out there and
Tick Tock influencers who think we're
just old and out of touch and don't know
what we're talking about trying to take
away your favorite app you may not care
that your data is being accessed now but
it will be one day when you do care
about it and here's the real problem
with data comes power they can choose
what you see and how you see it they can
make you believe things that are not
true they can encourage you to engage in
behavior that will destroy your life
even if it is not happening yet it could
in the future the long-term goal of the
Chinese Communist party is the demise of
the American power and that starts with
our youth at any moment they could
demand that all of tick tock's data be
used to design an AI algorithm with the
sole purpose of promoting Chinese
interests and destroying our society
from within you want to know why that's
Democrat why that's why Democrats and
Republicans have come together on this
that's why we are so concerned
man I just hope that he brought an extra
diaper because he just himself over
the you know like I mean he's he's an AI
algorithm just like trying to compute
doomsday scenarios right let's start
first with the idea that the Chinese
Communist party is controlling Tick Tock
in America is that plausible
I I mean I'm I'm not a China expert I
think these things are good to
interrogate but there is no evidence of
that and you know I think we saw that
them correcting that type of
misinformation I I think I mean I know
that China experts you know have
opinions about this but there's just we
have we need proof right to if we're
going to be making laws and we need this
we don't we don't have the Smoking Gun
it is what it is you know if that stuff
existed it would be a completely
different conversation as you'll note it
what he says what Crenshaw says many
times could this could happen this could
happen sure it could a lot of things
could happen but we don't we we need to
we need evidence that it is happening or
some sort of proof
could you could you also then the second
part of that the one is okay you know
that the Chinese government is behind
everything and that's you know why our
kids are increasingly dumb and I you
know whatever anxious depressed unsexual
or too sexual Etc but then there's the
the other implication in all of this is
that Tick Tock like all other social
media platforms before it is uniquely
addictive is there any reason to believe
that uh social media becomes you know
it's it's like watching the ring uh you
know the the the video in The Ring movie
from Japan that was and then had an
American version you know you watch it
and then 72 hours later you're going to
commit suicide
um could you talk a little bit about how
people actually use social media or
programs or platforms like tick tock are
they enslaved by it or do they actually
do a pretty good job of regulating and
moderating their use I mean I just think
it's like any form of entertainment do
people spend nine hours watching TV
sometimes in binging TV yes do people
play video games for 10 hours yes do
people spend too much time on social
media sometimes yes this is
entertainment as Tick Tock builds itself
as an entertainment company I don't know
if it's the government's role to come in
and regulate
you know how much time we're spending on
an entertainment platform I just that
seems dystopian I mean sometimes you
want to let loose and watch too much I
just think this is you know we need to
be able to
we take some sort of personal
responsibility here I mean we can't just
it's wild to me and the way he's talking
of you know as he mentions sort of
flippantly all social media companies
can do that those things that he's
listed those those examples he lists in
the beginning there is evidence that
Facebook has done every single one of
those things right there's evidence that
YouTube has done every single one of
those things there's not evidence that
Tick Tock has done those things do I
think that Tick Tock could sure it's a
social media it's an algorithmically
generated feed we know the problem well
I I speak as a survivor of the roller
disco craze of the late 70s and thank
God the government shut down all the you
know uh skating rinks otherwise I
wouldn't be here to talk uh or to
telltales but it's also true that
Facebook you know Facebook which is you
know by a large percentage the single
largest social media platform on the
planet at least in North America it
seems to be losing its grip I mean that
which is also one way we know this is
because they've been calling for
regulation at least since 2018 which is
typically a sign that a company is
losing Market strength and Market power
so they either play ball with the
government and they go to the government
as Mark Zuckerberg at one point did and
said like yeah yeah it's a good idea to
regulate us we'll help you regulate us
because we're the only ones who know our
business
yeah I mean I think I I think Facebook's
Facebook losing ground is what is also
you know they have lobbied very
aggressively against Tick Tock so much
of the stuff that you hear from Congress
people is you know basically Facebook
talking points and look I don't think
that I don't think the government should
be regulating how much time we spend on
Facebook either right like I mean I just
all of this is just seems very wild to
be having these discussions
yeah I agree uh that it that the I agree
with that fundamental assertion that the
government it shouldn't be the
government deciding how much time you
spend on Tick Tock or Facebook
um it or even if Tick Tock should be
allowed to exist within the United
States
um even if there are some concerns I
mean personally I am somewhat concerned
like I would I don't have tick tock on
my phone I don't use it some of my
anxiety is tied to my experience
reporting in Hong Kong and seeing how
the Chinese government acts I kind of
ask myself the question like would the
Hong Kong protesters use this app and I
think the answer is is definitely no
um there is uh you know there's there's
no direct line to the tick tock company
to the CCP there is a CCP member that is
part of bite dance and and that is
concerning to me that being said I think
sorry go ahead
true because
the thing that I think they said was
false and I never was um yeah I can pull
up
right here you know what is incredible
as as you're pulling that up uh you know
things like WhatsApp uh telegram signal
and other you know uh services that do
encryption and whatnot those are
flourishing as well so you know this
idea that Tick Tock is going to become
the one thing that rules us all seems
not only premature but just completely
delusional yeah um this is from a report
that was submitted to the Australian
um uh Congress uh on bite dance uh the
bite dance party secretary and chief
editor Zhang Fu ping
um declared that bite dance should uh
transmit correct political Direction
into every business and product line to
guide the algorithms and uh he's not
directly involved with Tick Tock he is
officially affiliated with the Chinese
side of the business the concern is that
there might be some crossover between
the two parts of the organization since
it's the same parent company that being
said I think that this is a kind of
buyer beware type of situation and I
think that's what Rand Paul was getting
at in his uh opposition he stood up and
opposed Senator Josh hawley's Bill and
we're going to play a clip from that in
a second because I'd like to get your
reaction to What Rand Paul pretty much
the sole Republican that that I know of
who has spoken out against the impending
Tick-Tock ban
I think we should be aware of those who
peddle fear I think we should be aware
of those who use fear to coax Americans
to relinquish our liberties to regulate
and limit our first amendment rights
every accusation of data Gathering
that's been attributed to tick tock
could also be attributed to domestic big
tech companies in fact one of the bills
they're looking at doing is Broad enough
that the president will be given the
power to designate whatever country he
sees fit to be an adversary and whatever
company underneath that definition it
would basically be a limitless Authority
for the president to ban speech before
Banning Tick-Tock these sensors might
want to discover that China already bans
tick-tock
hmm do we really want to emulate Chinese
speech bands aren't we the ones that say
it's wrong for China to ban speech so
we're going to be just like China and
ban speech we're afraid of
I hope Center Minds will reflect on
which is more dangerous videos of
teenagers dancing
or the precedent of the U.S government
Banning speech for me it's an easy
answer I will defend the Bill of Rights
against all comers even if need be from
members of my own party
what's your reaction to Rand Paul's
comments Taylor
yeah I mean exactly what he said it's
completely true like all of this stuff
about data privacy yes we have a few
huge data privacy problem in this
country the foreign adversaries want
data on uh U.S citizens very easy to get
because literally we have almost no
privacy regulations so you know he's I
mean I basically agree with everything
he said
um he also you know I I do love the
prospect of you know the 2024 election
being like the Footloose election where
it is going to come down to politicians
who want to ban dancing on Tick Tock uh
versus people who don't want to I think
we know how that movie ends but
um Taylor let me ask you because you
also uh you know and and I'm assuming
you feel a little bit uncomfortable
being on the same side of something with
Rand Paul uh partly because you've
talked a lot about misinformation
disinformation Mal information on social
media platforms you are steadfast and
saying you know it's insane for the
government to ban Tick Tock it's insane
for the government to tell us what
social media platform or you know what
what kind of media we can consume and
for how long what how do you go about
policing you know and these are
contested uh categories right of
misinformation disinformation
malformation how do you go about
policing that without abrogating
people's rights of self-expression and
freedom of speech yeah well it's always
bizarre to me when people accuse me of
saying like oh I want some sort of
censorship because I talk about
misinformation never once have I said
that like the government should be the
one determining what's misinformation or
censoring anything on social platforms I
have always said I think I I think
misinformation and disinformation look
as journalists here it's a huge problem
it's very frustrating people are grossly
misinformed on a lot of stuff because of
it the solution to that in my opinion is
better media literacy explaining to
people how these platforms work I mean I
always say the best way to debunk you
know of rumor and I've learned this
about rumors about myself right it's
it's it's not even to just say like
delete that right like get it taken down
it's to explain here's what's happening
right this person is lying here's why
they're lying here's the shape of this
campaign that it's taking right like I
just I think that the government does
not have a good track record on deciding
what's misinformation or not if they did
US reporters wouldn't have jobs right so
you know
um do you feel like
um you know kind of digital natives uh
you know and at this point I mean I
guess the the true generation that's
digitally native might be gen Z or
younger people but do you do you feel
like they are
um they're up to the challenge of that
kind of uh radical media literacy or
skepticism
um of you know of kind of vetting what
kinds of information they're they're
getting or are they even more kind of
prone to the sort of confirmation bias
that those of us who you know remember
the days of broadcast TV uh might be
yeah I mean look I think I think we have
a huge problem with media literacy in
this country across the board it's not
just Boomers it is also people on Tick
Tock I do believe everything they see on
Tick Tock and YouTube YouTube is a big
one that I hear all the time
um you know
are they up to the challenge maybe not
right now but they could be I mean I
think if we took this problem seriously
and if people in power took this problem
seriously we could have a better system
and we could have a more educated public
you know with a more diverse media
ecosystem by the way I'm a huge
proponent of independent journalism you
know journalists on social media people
getting their voices out not just these
Legacy systems
um and Legacy Media but
um but we need people in power to want
to do that and of course a lot of people
Empower their busy you know just
peddling their own brand of
misinformation so they don't really have
an interest in an educated public and
that's a huge problem that's been a
problem since even before social media I
mean I come I completely agree with
everything that you're saying there that
this this is the role of Journalism and
this is the challenge of our time is to
try to create an organic kind of uh
media literacy uh and like healthier
ecosystem but that's not what I've seen
unfold over the past say 5 five to seven
years what I've seen is a concerted
political effort starting around 2016 to
create a perceived crisis around myths
and disinformation and I this is now
converging with the fears of China and
both of these things have like a root
truth to them but politicians are
running with both of these things to now
this is to now exert what what we're now
seeing as the most authoritarian version
of a Crackdown on a social media app but
we've been seeing it build up to this
um in the ways that we've had these you
know kind of sketchy public-private
Partnerships in terms of policing this
and disinformation online so do you
worry uh I mean do you agree I guess
that there has been that the kind of
feeding into that that perceived crisis
uh and and the idea that the government
needs to act on that crisis has kind of
created the conditions for what we're
now seeing unfold with tick tock yeah I
mean I I think undeniably all of these
fears are playing into into this Tick
Tock stuff I think also these lawmakers
are being very Savvy in you know
touching on these lightning rod issues
that they know will instill fear and
panic
um I think it's just you know one thing
that I try and do with my reporting is
debunk things and and explain to people
how the internet works right and I don't
think that any of these lawmakers showed
very much understanding of how the basic
you know basic social media platforms
work how the internet works I mean the
Facebook hearings were equally as
painful this is not me just oh God they
were a national humiliation it was just
you know we need people in power that
understand these platforms intimately
and also are not just using them for
their own gain right like of course
they're going to use them to get elected
and stuff like that but but we need you
know people in power that aren't just
interested in their own power which is
very hard to find of course that's what
everyone in power just wants more power
but
um it's yeah it's disappointing to see
them rely on these these tropes and I do
think that you know debunking bad
information is important I think again
that's journalists do that every day and
there's ways that we can make a
healthier media climate that isn't
Banning apps or government crackdowns
all right we're going to leave it there
Taylor Lorenz of the Washington Post
most recently we'll have a bunch of
links to everything you do in the show
notes here so thank you very much for
joining us and uh the next time we get
together baby I you know I like to
prepare NyQuil Chicken in an insta pot
um you know I feel like it tenderizes
things and it makes the sleep a little
bit better but we'll see you uh
somewhere on the internet for the next
insane non-existent craze thanks so much
for joining us thanks for having me bye
Taylor
uh before we uh cut over to Peter Von
volkenberg of coin Center our next guest
I just want to run through a couple of
comments and questions
uh brand this uh win 2100 says Tick Tock
today reason tomorrow
uh not not if we have anything to say
about it uh fauer home says Tick Tock
definitely needs scrutiny the same with
uh Facebook and Instagram and others the
reality is that this technology has been
detrimental in its current form but the
government will abuse this you can say
that right Jimmy great says I was
against Tick Tock I still am but uh
recently I found crazy if you search
France on Instagram you will get fancy
good heart pictures but you type in
France and Tick Tock you will get the
truth not sure what that means Zach uh
do you have uh anything to add no I say
let's spring Peter into the conversation
okay here he is all right yes Peter Von
valkenburg and I apologize for
emphasizing your name and mispronouncing
it I'm sure from coinsetter thanks for
joining the reason live stream hey Nick
hey Zach really happy to be here and the
pronunciation was on base it was a
little heavily
it's you know it is a really kind of
like uh operatic name a vagnarian name
uh so you know I I envy that but
um let's start with uh you know if you
were listening in and particularly that
Rand Paul clip and whatnot you know the
restrict Act is supposed to ban
Tick-Tock but it actually does much more
than that and Tick Tock in the great you
know uh tradition of laws that are
obviously tailored to one thing but you
know but have much broader application
it doesn't actually mention Tick Tock
what does the restrict act do and what
should we be worried about yeah so it's
a extremely broad law and you know there
could be a good reason to not mention
Tick Tock to be just transparently clear
a law that specifically calls out a
corporation and finds them guilty of a
crime or a person for that matter would
be a bill of attainder unconstitutional
under our American system for other
reasons which that was Senator hawley's
Bill by the way uh and Rand Paul
specifically called him out for that
because Holly's bill was targeting
Tick-Tock and it's illegal exactly so we
don't have that infirmity with the
restrict act but we have a different one
and in many ways a a more dangerous one
because rather than zeroing in on a
specific Corporation or company Tick
Tock this bill is giving basically
unrestricted powers to the Secretary of
Commerce
to identify information Technologies and
transactions or Holdings Financial
Holdings related to those information
Technologies and simply say that
Americans are not allowed to make those
transactions or have those Holdings and
there's very little process for how they
make those determinations other than the
fact that the information technology is
advantageous to a foreign adversary I
guess in this case we're assuming it's
China but it could be anyone and there's
no limitations or there's very few
limitations
with regard to who can challenge or
rather there are limitations as to who
can challenge designations once they're
made by the Secretary of Commerce and we
can get more into that it's particularly
relevant to us at coin Center where
we're focused on cryptocurrency
Technologies because we're actually
fighting some of these sorts of battles
with respect to an existing statute for
sanctioning or blocking transactions the
international economic emergency Powers
Act and the ofac regime that comes from
that act of Congress so you know one
thing we've done is we look at the
restrict Act is compare and contrast
does this create new powers are we going
to be fighting treasuries ofac
designations as well as the Secretary of
commerce's restrict act designations and
would it be more or less difficult to
challenge Secretary of commerce's
designations under restrict then it has
been thus far for us to challenge oh
fact designations when they go beyond
the actual statutory Authority yeah
let's and let's get to that because the
restrict Act is really kind of applying
an existing law against various kinds of
you know that effect crypto and other
things to Media but I just want to say
you know to me part of what is strikes
me as insane about this it's a twofold
process first you have Congress actually
seeding so much power to the executive
branch you know this is a long-running
problem I think within a reason style
libertarian analysis of government
sometime over the past 50 years and
maybe maybe since Andrew Jackson
Congress has just stopped actually doing
what it's supposed to be doing and it's
just offloading you know it's it's it's
Outsourcing what it's supposed to be
doing to Congress which is nuts
to begin with and then so there's that
problem and then it's like the Secretary
of Commerce there are probably 80
percent of the people in Congress could
not name who the Commerce Secretary is
and you give them massive broad Powers I
mean the Commerce Secretary is to the
you know to Cabinet offices what Cornell
is to the ivy league you know it's it's
a it's a secondary tertiary seller
dweller kind of cabinet level so it just
seems nuts that you know this this is
what's in front of us can you to be fair
there's some members of Congress who
aren't even aware that their own name is
a co-sponsor to the bill yeah no I mean
but this this gets to this right where
it's like
um you know Congress no longer I mean
they've you know they don't declare Wars
they don't do anything
um and like how do you how do you battle
that when you're you know when you're
talking about the restrict act and
earlier you know existing laws
um that end up giving massive amounts of
power to the administrative State
essentially
um you know how do you how do you start
clawing back
you know agency it's really hard because
as you said this has been going on for a
long time maybe since Andrew Jackson
certainly since the um
since the New Deal and and Roosevelt's
expansion of of the executive powers
therein and you know there's this public
facing rationale for that that a lot of
people have bought or or sort of bought
into for a long time now it goes all the
way back to Max Weber the sociologist
who said that as the subject of law the
things that law needs to regulate become
more complex and technological and he
was probably thinking about I don't know
steam engines and things like that but
God knows it's gotten more complex that
it will be inevitable that sort of
citizen-run legislatures will have to
give up their authority to a more
technocratic bureaucratic class and so a
lot of people I think that argument if
they're not if they're just sort of
casually observers of the political
process make sense but there's something
extremely Insidious in that argument
it's that we need to give up on elected
representatives being capable of
educating themselves sufficiently to
actually control the things that matter
most in society like our information
Technologies and our engineering
Technologies and what you end up with
then is where we are today where that
atrophy has got gotten so profound that
Congress really just sort of writes
blank checks all the time they say oh
tick tock's a problem here's a blank
check to the Secretary of Commerce to
make sure that they can ban anything
that they need to in their wisdom and
their technical expertise about the
internet that might be a threat to
American interests and that is just an
abdication of congress's Duty under the
Constitution which vests the sole
legislative power in congress not in the
executive the bright spot here and I
don't need to tell you Nick or you Zach
what this is is that our courts have
actually wised up to this and some of
our justices like Neil Gorsuch
especially are very keen to return that
separation of powers with with you know
important cases dealing with major
Powers Doctrine and the non-delegation
doctrine of the Constitution so that's
how you challenge us you challenge it in
court now hopefully we don't have to
bring a non-delegation challenge to the
restrict act because hopefully it never
passes into law but that's all a lot of
hopefully is right yeah let's look I
want to look at some of of the text here
just to underline or highlight exactly
how big of a blank check this is to the
Executive Branch the Commerce Secretary
in particular the law says the secretary
is authorized to and shall take action
to identify deter disrupt prevent
prohibit investigate or otherwise
mitigate
all of these threats that the secretary
determines poses an undo or unacceptable
risk of sabotage or subversion
that can include catastrophic effects on
the security or resilience of the
critical infrastructure or digital
economy of the United States which we
should talk about in a second here and
otherwise poses an undoer unacceptable
risk to the National Security of the
United States and then this one is the
one that blew my mind if the secretary
in his Sole and unreviewable discretion
determines that such a referral would be
in the interest of national security so
they're not missing any words as to you
know the kind of sole unreviewable
authority of this one executive
appointed official to affected a broad
swath undefinable uh swath of the
economy yeah um yeah my favorite in in
that is otherwise mitigate
so Congress is supposed to tell the
agencies in the executive branch you
know what the problem is and ideally
with some specificity like regulation of
the airwaves I.E we can't have
interference between different parts of
the Broadband spectrum and then ideally
supposed to direct them to how they're
supposed to you know carefully wield
their powers to enforce congress's will
otherwise mitigate is a completely
unbridled phrase I mean if you bomb a
data center you might otherwise mitigate
certain nasty effects coming out of that
data center surely that is not within
the intended powers that Congress seems
to be giving here but if you just look
at the plain language of the word
otherwise mitigate includes all kinds of
things that would be patently a
violation of Human Rights or Liberty or
the rule of law
there's also that phrase uh you know the
effects on the digital economy and you
were mentioning yeah you know you're
from coin Center you're concerned with
the effects of legislation on the
cryptocurrency uh the world
cryptocurrency uh I produced a
documentary last year that I'm going to
play a clip from in just a second about
the tornado cash Crackdown which I know
is is one of your your primary cases now
and I want to just play a clip from that
documentary to ex to build I think
briefly explain what's at stake here and
then have you talk about the way that
the restrict act expands upon the
currently existing sanctions regime that
is being used to choke
um some Innovative uses of
cryptocurrency August 8th was different
the U.S treasury Department announced it
was adding tornado cash a tool for
making cryptocurrency transactions
Anonymous to the US sanctions list Dutch
authorities arrested a suspected
developer of tornado cash accusing him
of facilitating laundering of billions
of dollars of stolen funds
tornado cache is what's known as a coin
mixer meaning it Blends together
multiple cryptocurrency transactions and
then breaks them out again with the
purpose of making it harder for sleuths
to follow the payment Trail it's a
technique for protecting Financial
privacy and has been used to avoid
detection by authoritarian governments
so tornado captures in ethereum based
coin mixer what is what is the gut what
does the government do what is the
status of that right now what and what
has the government done to throttle that
yeah so so at its heart tornado cash is
29 smart contracts on the ethereum
blockchain
um and these smart contracts what they
do is they allow someone who has
cryptocurrency say on their phone they
like hold it directly like you have cash
in your wallet move that into something
that's like a a special security safe
right and you get a little receipt when
you move it into that safe and only you
the person with the receipt can then
take it back to that online safe and get
it out of there now if lots of people
all put their money in the same safe but
only ever retain control of their own
particular deposit to that safe then
there can be privacy because we can't
unchain identify who put money in that
corresponds to any particular withdrawal
and this is very important because if
we're going to actually they build our
entire digital economy on these new
distributed Ledger Technologies
permissionless blockchains we're going
to need a measure of privacy now to a
lot of people you know especially maybe
folks in government that sounds like I'm
talking about like well we should enable
people to launder money and things like
that and let's be clear that privacy
tools are going to be used by bad people
to do bad things but privacy tools are
also used by good people to do
completely ordinary things so ofac the
office of financial asset control which
enforces U.S sanctions policy identified
these core smart contracts and said
Americans aren't allowed to use them
anymore why because we've seen our
foreign enemies allegedly North Korean
hackers in the Lazarus group move money
through these software contracts in
order to hide them from investigators
but they're not saying that the Lazarus
group is itself alone sanctioned they're
actually saying these software contracts
are sanctioned that the Lazarus group
has used therefore for we're not just
trying to stop the Lazarus group from
using them we're trying to stop ordinary
Americans from using them for their own
privacy so coin Center is challenging
that designation along with some
similarly situated co-pointives the
reason coin Center has status or
standing to challenge that designation
is because we've actually received
donations to our 501c4 non-profit that
have gone through tornado cash because
someone wanted to politically associate
with us which is first amendment
protected by making a donation but they
wanted it done privately I.E so that
some random person in the in the public
can't just see the ethereum transaction
directly and know that this person's a
supporter of coin Center but we wanted
to make sure we had copientists because
we don't want this to look like just a
particular issue cryptocurrency advocacy
and our copliances are really
interesting one of them is an ordinary
American who gets paid on the ethereum
blockchain as a software developer
because that's where his software
actually runs that's where he does his
work and all he wants is privacy over
his paycheck not from the IRS he's still
obligated to sell report his income just
from like the guy in the next cubicle
who would otherwise be able to see it on
the ethereum blockchain perfectly
reasonable and then another one of our
coplanatives is somebody who's actually
anonymous because and it'll make sense
for uh for why in a second because what
they've been doing using tornado cash is
facilitating donations to the war effort
in Ukraine to defend against the Russian
aggression there and the reason why he's
doing this using tornado cash is because
there's a very real fear that if you or
people who you're working with are
making donations to support Ukraine's
defense the gru will identify those
transactions on the blockchain and
Target you for cyber attacks so these
are completely legitimate indeed in many
cases First Amendment protected
transactions money can be speech and yet
these are now forbidden for Americans to
make even if they're made with no
connection to a foreign adversary to a
foreign government because again if I
take my money put in a tornado cash and
take it out myself at no point have I
paid anyone in North Korea and the the
suggestion that I have is really just a
a lie being propagated in order to
further control I think over software
that we should all have the access to do
you go ahead Zach sorry I was just gonna
say so this is an example of using that
kind of hop skip and jump to a foreign
adversary use this technology therefore
anyone else who touched this technology
we're going to use this sanctions regime
to ban the technology itself so how does
the restrict act build upon that idea
and in your opinion worsen it right so
this is all that we've been describing
about tornado cash are sanctions that
have been taken under the international
emergency economic Powers Act daipa
which has been law for a long time in
fact it descends from the trading with
the Enemy Act that statute is Law and
treasury enforces it the restrict act
would create what we would call a
parallel regime a whole nother system of
blocking and sanctioning Americans from
using certain or making certain
transactions and how is it in the
Secretary of Secretary of commerce's
office one thing from a political angle
that I think is is rather interesting is
how the financial services subcommittees
in the house and the Senate and the
Banking Committee in the Senate feel
about this they had primary oversight
over this very powerful tool to block
transactions and now they're going to be
sharing it with the Commerce committees
so this might be a good way to actually
politically challenge the advancement of
this legislation but that's or inside
game politics and less actually
sentenced in the law but there's some
other issues with the restrict act that
are that that bear repeating as you see
coin Center is already having at least
some difficulty challenging the tornado
cash restrictions I mean we're doing it
we're in court we're in the 11th circuit
we're down in Florida and we think we
have a good chance of winning now with
the restrict act there's some things
that are different probably because you
know those who want this unbridled power
to block Technologies and transactions
see that there are some limitations in
ofac and want to remove those
limitations so that they truly can do
this with impunity and with less chance
of a civil liberties organization like
coin Center knocking on their door and
saying you can't do that so the big
difference is and I'll just say them
briefly so everyone can be on the same
page is that the restrict act unlike
iepa for ofac sanctions has no statutory
carve out for transactions that are
dealing primarily in protected speech
activities
ayipa the president is allowed to block
all kinds of transactions they can't
block a transaction where all that's the
subject of the transaction is like art
from an artist in Cuba being sold to an
American in fact there's case law about
this and that would be a First Amendment
argument you could make you can't block
these transactions because this is
protected speech but in the context of
aipa and ofac unlike the restrict act
you can make a statutory law argument
you could say Congress didn't even
intend to give this power whether or not
it's constitutional we don't have to
reach that question so it's another
Avenue to challenge the statute without
bringing the more serious and
consequential constitutional challenge
you probably want to bring both but in
the restrict act you can't bring a
statutory challenge because there's no
carve out for information probably by
Design because they want to block a lot
of information Technologies and don't
want this pesky limitation on which
transactions can be censored
briefly the other ones that are simpler
to explain so I'll just lay them out
yeah
um there's no APA challenges it
precludes almost all administrative
procedure act challenges so unlike in
the tornado cash case where we're
arguing that the designation's arbitrary
and capricious under the administrative
procedure act you could not necessarily
make those claims uh under the restrict
act if you were challenging a
designation there and then the third one
that bears mentioning that's also quite
quite important although a little odd is
with ofac designations you can challenge
them anywhere in the country wherever
maybe you as a plaintiff happen to
reside and is convenient to you we're
challenging in the Western District of
Florida because the guy who gets paid on
ethereum and just wants privacy over his
income that's where he does his work
that's where venue is convenient and
that's where we want to bring the
challenge in that circuit
with restrict act challenges you are
limited to the DC circuit which means if
you had a plaintiff in California they
have to travel to DC for certain
depositions and other things and also
this is nakedly political the DC circuit
is inherently more friendly towards
administrative power and less
less likely to validate rule of law
concerns I would say so this is nakedly
a way to force discussion over
challenges to a friendly Judiciary
rather than one that might be more
skeptical
uh can we put this both the existing
laws and the restrict act the proposal
can we put it in a larger context about
you know the battle which is you know
has always been going on in America
between kind of the forces of
centralization and decentralization
there's a phenomenal book that was first
published in 1955 by the political
scientists and historian Arthur ekirch
the decline of American liberalism who
said even before the the United States
existed as as a set of colonies the
forces of centralization versus
decentralization have been at War and
you know it's just you know kind of each
year uh is defined by whether we're more
centralized or more decentralized in the
90s as the internet
um kind of rose to mass medium
status through uh you know the the
creation of the World Wide Web there was
a glorious kind of decentralization you
know and this is you know when you read
the early issues of wired uh and
discussions about disintermediation
where finally people would be freed free
to kind of communicate directly transact
directly kind of get in touch without
middlemen or overseers and Gatekeepers
doing everything when you think back to
people like John Perry Barlow of the
Electronic Frontier Foundation uh you
know talking about the Declaration of
Independence in cyberspace where he was
kind of writing off you know these
rotting hulks of of you know lumbering
corporations and governments of the
Industrial Age like you you mean nothing
anymore
since uh you know maybe from like 95 to
about 2005 there was decentralization
there's been a recentralization uh and
going back to you know whether it is
Facebook and kind of trying to create a
Walled Garden model or Twitter all of
the social media platforms you know try
to keep you within their kind of
confines they de-prioritize things that
link outside of them this type of thing
um you know but in the teens and started
you know starting particularly with
Bitcoin uh you know this idea of uh of a
not just a stateless currency but one
that would be harder to track harder to
impose controls over uh you know it was
self-reinforcing
um we are now at a stage where you see
people like Jack Dorsey the former CEO
and co-founder of Twitter pushing things
like Noster uh you know a decentralized
the distributed uh kind of social media
messaging platform the rise of telegram
signal WhatsApp also sorts of things
even if they're somewhat centralized in
some way they event end encryption can
you put the restrict act and other
conditions and particularly what seems
to be a growing attempt to essentially
ban or prohibit Bitcoin and other types
of cryptocurrency can you put it in that
larger context are we seeing kind of is
this the Revenge of uh you know is it is
it the Revenge of the Empire trying to
stamp out all of these attempts at
decentralization or are we actually
achieving escape velocity and going we
won't be worrying about this because the
technology will free us you know in a
few years
so putting in context I agree complete
with your characterization of these
cycles of decentralization and
centralization it was growing up in the
internet of the 90s and deciding what I
wanted to do with my life that made me
so excited about going to law school you
know weirdly enough it was I want to be
like John Barry Barlow he was a hero of
mine I want to fight that fight and then
things changed right and now now we're
in this situation your your listeners
will almost certainly be familiar with
Bruce yandel's concept of the
bootleggers and the Baptists right so
this is an idea in public Choice Theory
political Theory wherein when Congress
or some policy maker wants to pass a law
um they might have two people whispering
in their ear they'll have the Baptists
who say alcohol is really bad uh it
breaks families apart and this is all
true so you should pass this law for
that reason prohibition but you also
have the Bootleggers who say wouldn't it
be great if alcohol was illegal because
then our criminal Enterprise of
transporting alcohol across state
borders will just boom and the reality
is a lot of the money that goes into
supporting these efforts is coming from
the cynical side that just wants to get
richer and they have a public-facing uh
face for why it's a good idea and this
is I think a prime example of this
because I'm quite sure that most of the
political will behind the restrict Act
is not actually interested in Banning
decentralized Technologies
they're interested in Banning Tick Tock
possibly having greater control over
Facebook or the other centralized Giants
that even John Perry Barlow probably
would have thought were kind of a nasty
evolution of the internet
but what will this broad law actually be
used for I think it will be used to
bring the hammer down on decentralized
Technologies so in a certain sense The
Bootlegger here might be the giant Tech
corporations who want their monopolies
protected against foreign big tech
companies but more insidiously against
decentralizing Technologies and what's
the Baptist here the public face oh it's
the tick tock's bad it's not that we're
actually going to use this law to to to
to to block open source software
although it could be used to block both
and I carry very little water for tick
tock because I agree the internet was
better when it was all protocols when
you were using your own you know HTTP to
write a blog you were using
um SMTP to send an email and that's what
Bitcoin and open protocols like ethereum
and such are are there to do is to
return us to that that better world
where we're just more equals online
rather than all subject to someone's
Walled Garden all right well uh suggest
I mean I I agree with you completely and
and maybe in a certain way you the
utopian outcome is where you have both
walled Gardens and distributed protocols
or protocols that allow for just you
know distributed Enterprises to kind of
live and because you know there is
something nice about being able to go to
one place and have a big audience I
before we go I would also add the power
laws are immutable so there's a certain
amount of decentralization and
recentralization that will always occur
and the importance is to keep dynamism
in the economy yeah I don't mean to
colonize big Tech uh
but we need to keep the cycle moving and
if we use a power like the restrict act
to stop the cycle and say we're just
going to stay centralized now but
American centralized not Chinese
centralized then that's and we've seen
this happen in various ways and and
virtually in every major industry uh
sector over time you know the automakers
that it Uber and Lyft to a degree did
this where you know they disrupted cab
companies which were state granted
monopolies everywhere State licensed and
regulated and the minute they got a
really good market share they would go
to state legislators or city councils
and say hey you know what we need we we
agree with you we need to restrict or we
need to regulate things better to make
sure nobody gets hurt and it would just
happen to freeze them at a point in the
market cycle where they were at the uh
you know they were at the top of the
pyramid I just wanted to say before we
go to Zach for people interested in a
fantastic
insanely libertarian movie about baptist
Bootlegger uh coalitions Legends of the
Fall From the 90 which is by Edward
zwick and it has Anthony Hopkins and
Brad Pitt in it Julia pinoche I believe
um it is it's it is this insanely
libertary movie which takes place during
um prohibition and a minor spoiler alert
it ends with a congressman shooting
revenuers who are coming uh who are
working for Bootleggers Etc but it's uh
it's it's a fascinating concept and
Legends of the Fall uh is a pretty good
movie on that score Zach
I wanted to raise another kind of big
picture question here which is
it's related to the centralization
decentralization question and you you
kind of mentioned the difference between
American style centralization and China
style centralization and that is what
something like the restrict Act is
trying to cope with it it feels like uh
we're and it goes beyond social media
companies it's really about what is the
future of U.S China relations and and
what do you do when you have an open
system
interacting with a closed system because
as we mentioned earlier with Taylor
Lorenz
China doesn't allow Tick-Tock uh the the
the more freewheeling algorithm to run
in its country uh we allow it here Rand
Paul made the point in his speech that
well we don't want to emulate the
Chinese system you know we don't want to
be China and and banning things but if
you for people who are concerned about
Tick Tock in particular or big Tech more
broadly what are some better solutions
to deal with that problem of of possibly
either malevolent actor or just one that
doesn't have your best interests in mind
and is you know hoovering up data all
the time and using it in ways that you
don't want it to be used are there you
know good non-state solutions for that
or or even State solutions that don't
involve passing a bill that is you know
extremely broad concentrates all its
power in one executive agency and is
almost impossible to challenge unless
you can get to the Supreme Court or
something yeah I mean ideally we would
have emergent bottom-up Solutions maybe
Market Solutions even more interesting
maybe like mutualism type Solutions
where people just build communities
online together and are able to actually
sort of set their own rules I think
that's the kind of thing that a John
Perry Barlow who was a cattle rancher
for a long time would like you know he's
probably concerned about what his kids
are seeing on social media but wouldn't
it be great then if he was able to be
part of a larger community that sort of
was the Walled Garden they they are the
wall Garden they set the rules for
content in their neighborhood and then
they can have strong Norms about how
kids you know you know should should be
on this social network rather than
another the tools for building those
decentralized social networks those ones
that are actually bottom up and emergent
and reflect the values of the community
rather than the values of someone in
Silicon Valley or in Shanghai or more
likely a Beijing actually you know those
tools are things like ethereum like
Bitcoin cryptocurrencies this gets back
to what Nick was saying about Jack
Dorsey at Twitter you know the guy who
invented one of these big platforms that
exercises a tremendous amount of
editorial control over what's healthy
for people to read or unhealthy for
people to read which is a very
subjective designation he himself is
sort of I I suppose you could see it
almost as a Maya culpa I you know I
thought this was the right way to build
it at the time and maybe it was the only
way to build it at the time because it
was before Bitcoin really
um but now I think that there's better
ways to build these things and that's
why I think he is supporting efforts
like Noster or blue sky there's a whole
bunch of these projects they're in their
infancy though and they're very readily
susceptible to being sort of um
strangled in the Cradle if you will by
somebody who actually secretly really
does like the power that a few
centralized intermediaries provide them
to shape the message for Americans so
that's that's what's going on right now
can I ask the follow follow up uh you
know in this uh in this vein a couple of
months ago at the atlas Network which is
a uh a think tank that funds think tanks
mostly in the developing uh world uh and
kind of pushing back against
authoritarian governments you know it's
freedom of speech rule of law free
markets and things like that I
interviewed Alex Gladstone of the human
rights Foundation who's you know a great
Bitcoin and crypto evangelist and he was
saying that you know it it was hard for
people to remember how to use email or
to remember their their passwords you
know 25 30 years ago
um it's not going to be it shouldn't if
people can do that they can remember
their crypto Keys Etc I mean part of
what's it seems to me part of the
stumbling block of the um adoption of a
lot of these new re-decentralized
disintermediate protocols and whatnot is
that it is pretty confusing it's pretty
difficult and it's daunting to people
and I said that if somebody I always try
to do early adoption but you know Noster
Zach had to help me set up my account
there I'm on Mastodon which I always
call Mammoth because I'm becoming an old
man and I think I like mammoths better
than mastodons but like it's kind of
difficult and you know a couple
years ago reason minted a uh nft that we
sold up myself and my colleagues on the
reason Roundtable podcast and it was
like really difficult to just put a bid
in on on open C uh for this uh for this
nft
is the how how much easier does it need
to become for people to use these new
emerging Technologies for them to to
adapt and is that is that onus really on
the developers of this stuff or is it on
the rest of us to kind of up our game
and learn how to you know I I guess a uh
a metaphor of this is in the 80s when I
was younger and I didn't have money in
my time time was literally worth less
than it is now I would do my own
tune-ups oftentimes up my car
but like I would replace the spark plugs
I would do this I would do that when you
open a car up now there are very few
parts that anybody other than a you know
a really Certified mechanic who works in
a shop with a lot of computer technology
and specialized things can do I mean
like what what has to happen to make
Bitcoin to make crypto uh to make uh
distributed uh you know sensor uh proof
kind of communications more likely to
become robust yeah I mean I'd love to
I'd love to blame policy makers for this
but I can't I can only blame our space
um this technology is very Advanced and
very you know complex and so its
evolution is I think inherently slow on
some level you know in the in the car
repair context you can't actually blame
policy makers in many cases because
enforce copyright laws and other
intellectual property laws that actually
prevent you from being able to even log
into the computer that's in your car
unless you're an authorized repair I
mean is it still technically is it still
technically a felony a federal crime to
decrypt a uh a DVD
yeah yeah you know I mean just the rip
one so it's like yeah I mean there's
definitely laws that are against them
the anti-circumvention provisions of the
DMS dcma
um yeah so look
we have some issues with legal a lack of
clarity that has perhaps stymied and
slowed the development of this
technology I I'm not trying to minimize
those
um but the real problem is as you said
that the technology is still difficult
to use and I often uh I often have this
thought of the sort of different type of
dystopian outcomes that we fear and I
grew up thinking I was a sort of 1984
guy like we're gonna have big brother
we're gonna have one world government or
you know Atlantic versus Oceana whatever
it is in the book and we're not going to
be allowed to use technologies that we
would otherwise willingly choose to use
that protect our autonomy and our
privacy it turns out that we don't
really have so much of a big brother
problem not here in the U.S yet unless
things like the restrict act end up the
norm have this problem in China we have
a Brave New World problem which is
the centralized services that collect
all our information report our financial
transactions under the BSA or other Mass
surveillance statutes are so much nicer
and pleasant to use that we're sort of
um willingly able to and interested in
taking that drug because it's it's like
Soma in in huxley's Brave New World it
just makes us feel cozy and comfortable
even though in the long run it probably
erodes our mental health as we're seeing
with a lot of centralized social media
and ultimately causes us to become
docile and subservient and willing to
accept authoritarian rule and that's
terrifying because
this means you can't just say try harder
everyone
um use the product that's terrible
because it protects your autonomy and
privacy even though it's much harder to
use and so the onus really is on
technology
um technologists software developers in
our space to make these new systems not
just able to protect privacy and
autonomy but also 10 times more pleasant
and easier to use than the current
centralized Alternatives and I am
optimistic that we are finally getting
to that you know back when I started at
coin Center in 2014 it wasn't long after
that that Mark Andreessen from entries
and Horowitz wrote his now somewhat
Infamous we are in the 1998 of the
internet for crypto which meant we were
a couple years away from Main Street
truly mainstream usage of crypto that's
turned out not to be right just to give
your listeners who are not familiar with
crypto a sort of justification is why
it's been harder than expected there's
two big
um technological roadblocks that we're
only now seeing really really serious
efforts to solve one is scale if you
have a global Ledger of everything that
everyone has done it is incredibly heavy
duty as far as the amount of data that
needs to be verified and shared amongst
everyone so we can all trust that data
it's much easier if you just have a
centralized database to do that with
layer 2 networks built on top of
ethereum of which there are several
competitors and brand new layer 1
networks that could be an alternative to
bitcoin and ethereum we're finally
solving those problems by basically
being able to compress millions of
transactions that deal with little
personal interactions into smaller like
single transactions or smaller amounts
that then we can still have the same
validity everyone can still check that
their particular transaction is valid
but we didn't all have to have the same
amount of data to verify everything so
that's the sort of scaling Solutions and
some of them deal with zero knowledge
proofs that can also preserve privacy in
the process which is interesting because
public ledgers like Bitcoin can be bad
for privacy and some of them have to do
with other cryptographic constructs like
domestic settlement and things like this
the other half is what you were saying
earlier holding a private key is not
that much easier in fact it's a little
harder even than remembering a password
and that's a real problem if the way
you're going to interact with these
systems is sort of raw and on the edge
as a user of an open source Software
System rather than a customer of a
company you're going to have to be
really serious about data security and
most Americans aren't and so if you tell
them you lose your password to this
service because it's not a company it's
a network you're out of luck they
can't change it no one can change it
that's that makes the service much worse
as far as usability even though it's
what makes it good as far as personal
autonomy there's some really interesting
advances in self-sovereign identity in
um in account abstraction is the term
for it that can make it so that maybe
you could set up a system where you are
recognized as you on the network because
50 of your closest friends continue to
you know in a random in a regular way a
test that you are still you and you if
you lose your phone or the way you are
currently connecting to the network
five of those 50 friends could co-sign
to say this is your new phone this is
actually a really good bottom-up
Community focused Solution that's a sort
of like the way Americans have always
done things is by having strong local
communities so that we don't need to
rely on a sovereign or a central
authority to do the things we want to do
in our lives building those sort of
multi-sig multi-signature many people
all coming together to prove some fact
about a person building those systems
has been hard but I think they're on the
horizon and that combined with the
ability to scale the global networks
will mean that we'll finally have better
Tech that's sort of a long dissertation
on why I think we're about to overcome
some of these problems but the the
bigger answer to your original question
is we need to overcome those problems
because you can't convince people to
take their privacy seriously you have to
show them a tool that allows them to
take it seriously but is easier to use
than the existing tool that was
exploitative of their information you
know in the in the short term before we
get to that wonderful world where these
things are turnkey
you know if we are stumbling towards
Brave New World and basically the
choices are going to be you take the
American government Soma or the Chinese
government Soma or you figure out some
way not to take it at all and you know
live a Freer life what what practical
steps uh because I do agree with you
that there does it does seem like the
agenda the bipartisan agenda at this
point seems to be well
we can't allow it's the damn Crenshaw
argument we can't allow this digital
opium from overseas into our country we
just need to have our own safer Supply a
bit that we control uh in this country
and it doesn't and it's not just about
social media I mean I I pulled another
screenshot from the law here this is
these are some of the this is some of
the infrastructure that could be
affected by the restrict act Wireless
local area networks mobile networks
satellite payloads wireless access point
Edge compute platforms cloud-based
computer storage machine learning
Predictive Analytics you know a the
whole AI they're trying to kind of get
ahead of AI I think uh set up a
regulatory framework for that manage
service content delivery services so
that this is I it's hard to see it as
anything other than a power grab so
given that we're in that world what are
some practical steps the individual
consumer someone who's not super
technical who's not a crypto nerd can do
to kind of protect themselves against
that
protect themselves against the restrict
Act
not against the restrict act but against
the kind of ever more aggressive uh just
like hoovering up all your data uh or
kind of foisting
um very curated
uh dumps of information on you
I mean get off social media
I mean I
I was funny
um
my wife and I were remarking earlier
today about how our parents are on
Facebook but we're not anymore and
they've got this like interesting closed
loop now to actually talk about us
um I like that for my health that's not
a very satisfying answer to your
question I'm sure but you know like
experiment with new tools
um find tools that reflect your values
again I I I'm not too optimistic that
the majority of Americans will be
interested in doing that because those
tools are still very difficult to use
but that's the ultimate goal and then
from a policymaker perspective you know
what I'd say is you're right to be
worried about this but the American
response to these big
um you know intermediaries that control
the narrative and effectively have a
degree of mind control over their users
is not to lock it down that's that's the
North Korean approach this is what we've
said in our tornado cash lawsuit you
know the tornado cash lawsuit is
triggered in some ways by allegedly
North Korean hackers using this software
to launder ransomware payments
the solution to that is not to become
North Korea
the solution to that is to let let good
information out compete bad information
rather than saying that we're gonna like
have a centralized Authority for what
information Americans are have access to
or can't control and so unfortunately we
just have to be patient we have to be
patient for these more decentralized
solutions to become readily available
and popular and used and the worst thing
we could do is rather than being patient
for those alternatives to percolate up
say give Congress or or rather the
executive unbridled authority to block
those new technologies because they'll
probably end up using those blocking
powers to block open source software
that is the answer to these problems
rather than just using them or or using
them to to block big corporations that
are that are abusing our data or
collaborating with governments to abuse
our data
uh let's just I just want to go through
to a couple of questions or comments and
they seem to be mostly comments uh Jill
elswick writes that schools don't teach
media literacy because it makes people
confront the topic of their own biases
and no one enjoys that
Christopher mizlucky Mize lucky says in
Canada
our government is trying to push through
via a coalition of other parties a bill
to censor our internet in the name of
curbing misinformation Etc U.S citizens
need to oppose outright
sr1034 says could gov use tornado cash
also and SWA uh that might ask a
question for uh Peter um yeah let's and
let me just run through the last thing
the bill can limit the restrict act and
limit freedom of speech for All American
citizens it's crazy but let's and that
was from svok
XZ I feel like I'm in uh Anthem by Ein
Rand at this point uh but to go back to
sr1034 uh question could gov use tornado
cash also
yeah we know the Korean government a
North Korean government has right
you know it's interesting it it's not as
crazy a question as it might seem Tor
which is a mixing Network for internet
packets was developed by Naval signals
intelligence because and and was later
um used extensively by the the foreign
intelligence Service as a way of
protecting agents in the field who need
to communicate back over the Internet
um to their authorities in Langley or or
wherever they happen to be and
interestingly you'd think okay well then
why didn't they just lock down Tor and
make it a tool exclusively for the US
government right and why would you want
your enemies to have that tool or just
ordinary Americans who are trying to do
weird things to have that tool and the
answer is the tool only works if
everyone uses it this is the kind of
amazing public good nature of privacy if
you have this
um that that great old uh show get smart
where the cone of silence would come
down beautiful yeah and the portable
cone of silence that they could put like
bubbles it was like Habitrail to the
funny thing is
people in the cone of silence you know
those two people are talking and this is
the same Mentor if the only people who
use Tor in Iran are CIA agents you can
still identify tour traffic and if
you're the Iranian authorities you go
and you arrest those people who are
using torque because you know they're
CIA agents if on the other hand all
kinds of people
Iranians Americans CIA agents non-ca
agents are using the same Tech you can
no longer identify the traffic you have
to assume that some of these people
might be people you want to protect and
some of these people might be people you
don't like but you think all right well
privacy is just worth it so we'll let
the whole thing go and so that's what
Naval signals intelligence did they said
we're going to open source tour everyone
should be able to use it tornado cash
should be the same ideally if we need to
make payments to agents in the field
peer-to-peer cryptocurrency networks are
the best way to do it bitcoin's not a
great way to do it though at least not
in its native form because that traffic
is immediately identifiable and if you
can use clustering analysis to identify
that these are the CIA addresses and
these are the agent addresses then
that's the end if you'll get a
prediction just like you do in the
correspondent banking system or or in
regular Financial systems and so they
probably should use this technology
maybe they have I don't know but this is
another reason to preserve it because it
actually strengthens in many ways our
cyber security and National Security
interests because we're the country
that's anti-fragile that can survive an
unbridled information landscape China
can't the more those people in that
country wake up to what the Communist
party is doing to them the more they're
going to resist and the harder it is the
more expensive it is to maintain that
regime and so you know we should be all
for open Technologies and we should be
offer technologies that allow
individuals to privately talk to each
other because America is not afraid of
people talking about its government that
is uh you know uh it's a fascinating
point to make and I I'm going to ask you
what is the role of ideology sir you
know more than technology and kind of
winning these sorts of battles to you
know keep the internet open you know
which I I know it was kind of like the
equivalent of keeping Austin weird or
something like that
um because it is it's it seems to me we
no longer as Americans and the internet
in a very profound way and I don't mean
that America owns the internet but the
the best part of America as a kind of
ideological experiment or an aspiration
really did help structure the internet
and everything that goes with that in
terms of things like open source and
things like people being able to use
anonymous speech uh you know it's hard
to remember uh but you know these this
history which is not ancient history but
it's totally forgotten AOL which you
know is a joke now one of the one of the
selling propositions of AOL besides ease
of use and ubiquity uh you know it was a
local call to to call dial into the AOL
Network whereas other places other
internet service providers you you know
it might be a toll caller a long
distance call it costs real money but
AOL was Anonymous you could choose to be
very Anonymous and they were actually
very good at like resisting attempts to
uh you know kind of name or docks their
users even when uh you know law
enforcement came calling but how much of
it is recapturing
you know that American tradition of
anonymous speech we in in a profound way
America is a country founded on
Anonymous speech and privacy that goes
along with that you know what what do we
do to kind of build out the ideological
case for lack of a better word that
openness is better than Mass
surveillance
I mean this is why I love my job at coin
Center
um because our mission is to defend the
freedom to innovate using these
Technologies to make it clear that if
you're a software developer and you're
an American software developer and you
believe in building the right systems
that we've got your back and we've got
your back ideologically because you
might think this is just a good tool and
that's your Prime motivation for doing
it but also what you're doing publishing
code on the Internet is a
constitutionally protected activity and
so prior restraint on that in this
country is not allowed in Canada it
might be more easily restricted in China
it could be very easily restricted and
so that ideology and also just the base
constitutional law of our system is
extremely important you know the other
thing I wanted to briefly mention too
because it's sort of it it flows into
this is cbdc's central banks currencies
which in many ways have become a sort of
bogeymon a bogeyman
um uh in the crypto Community because
we're afraid that this is going to be
like a top-down surveillance effort to
get people to use this a US digital US
dollar instead of Bitcoin and then
actually capture all that information
that is a very accurate description of
how China is implementing cbdc's with
their their ecny program their cutting
the banks the private private
state-owned Banks out of the information
Loop and the informations of individual
atomistic transactions are going
straight to the government and the
surveillance apparatus in the US though
it doesn't have to be that way I think
it would be very good and even and I
might be
um you know rustling ruffling some
feathers in the cryptocurrency community
I think it'd be very good for there to
be a digital dollar that embodies
American principles that is a bearer
instrument like a hundred dollar bill in
your pocket is and that is private like
a hundred dollar bill in your pocket and
that could be government issued with the
support of the private sector probably
private sector technology providers and
it could be as private as cash and this
is something where actually we might
find sort of the Horseshoe of politics
bending together on the left and the
right because the left is often very
concerned about privacy and private
payments and also wants money as a
public good
and the right is also very concerned
about privacy and private payments and
so maybe you get some marriage here and
I tell you this if the U.S issued a
digital dollar
and it was as private as cash and as
autonomy protecting his cash like once I
get it from the government I can give it
to anyone and no one's the wiser and no
one can stop me that will immediately
dollarize the entire Internet to the
extent why would why would the US
government do that though uh because it
seems I mean you know when there is a
global attack on cash the only reason
that you use cash is for illegal
purposes right criminal behavior is the
only use case I mean this you hear
increasingly and you know that the
percentage of transactions that are
actually in cash continues to shrink and
Shrink why would the government why
would the US government actually issue a
central bank digital currency that it
could not trace and turn on and off or
or penalize the uh the bearer of that so
the the the optimistic or the Baptist
answer
is because it's ideological it embodies
American principles of freedom and
privacy The Bootlegger answer is because
it increases American hegemony for the
next Century if the US dollar is used
globally and the only and the way we can
bootstrap that is because people really
want to have private and Anonymous
transactions with the dollar then that
that does so much more to improve our
national security and our geopolitical
positioning for them especially at a
time where it does look like the dollar
you know the old school the you know uh
20th century dollar may be starting to
you know the challenges to it as the uh
Reserve currency are growing
um are there any people in college I
follow up one question on the cpdc angle
though because what would you be looking
for in that I I you're in addition to
being affiliated with coin Center you're
also on the board with Z cash which is a
privacy centered coin uses technology
called called zero knowledge proofs that
that you talked about earlier is that
the kind of technology that you would be
looking to be integrated into a private
cbdc in order to be able to trust that
there's no back door 100 yeah okay yeah
there's is an interesting thing so so
I'm at the Z cash foundation on the
board of directors
um there's also a company called the
electronic coin company that develops
that software and there's a bunch of
third-party developers and this is why
it's not centralized and why you can you
don't have to trust one of us you don't
have to trust me when you use zcash it's
just software that we all work together
to publish to a peer-to-peer Network and
anyone can audit that software and run
it now there's two things about Bitcoin
or about Z cash and specific
specifically that are interesting you
know one is the monetary function
there's only ever going to be 21 million
Bitcoins it's actually the same in Z
Cash There's only ever going to be 21
million units of zcash the other is the
peer-to-peer transfer function and the
Privacy they're in Bitcoin doesn't have
much privacy because everything ends up
on a public Ledger with zcash there's
these cryptographic constructs called
zero knowledge proofs which we don't
have to go into that allow anyone to
look at The Ledger and say I know the
money that just ended up in my wallet
was not double spent it's not
counterfeit but I don't actually know
who it came from it's a it's a zero
knowledge proof it proves one thing
about a transaction that it's not
counterfeit doesn't prove all sorts of
other details that people might want to
keep private now if you were going to
build a government issued but actually
Bearer instrument like fully private
digital currency the part of those two
technological constructs you change is
who can issue you wouldn't make it a a
finite amount because in theory you
still want to maintain monetary policy
for the issuer the ability to make more
or make less and that that opens up a
whole other economic question but this
is the dollar this is not digital gold
this is the dollar so you've loosened
the technical constraints there the
minting function is provided by a
centralized entity the U.S treasury or
the Federal Reserve
um
but the peer-to-peer transfer and the
zero knowledge proof functionality is
still verified in public
and still as with zcash does not reveal
additional information about
transactions such that I can't see your
transactions Nick to Zach but also the
mint that actually created these digital
dollars also can't see them there are
ways sort of like Odysseus binding
himself to the Mast for someone in that
position of Power with respect to the US
dollar to actually credibly do it not
just in law but in technology using
these peer-to-peer networks so we would
if that's a political will to ever do it
and I know I sound like I have two heads
to some people now no no well I was
going to ask are there any politicians
uh you know elected or otherwise that
are actually talking about this kind of
stuff because it really does seem and
like certainly when you look at the
restrict act hearings or The Tick Tock
hearings and the Facebook hearings
before that and the 2018 you know kind
of tech sector hearings politicians you
know a don't know what the they're
talking about but secondly are really
trying to to lock everything down like
nobody seems to be saying you know what
we need is an open-ended uh kind of set
of protocols that would actually be in
line with the American experiment and
would happen to have a knockout effect
of uh keeping America as if not the
essential Nation a central kind of uh uh
Crucible of meaning and decision making
and policy you know going into the 21st
century
so there are uh and interestingly there
are on both sides of the aisle
um
there was actually a bill that was
floated I think in
the 2020 Congress called the e-cash ACT
that directed the Secretary of Treasury
to develop a pilot digital dollar that
would be Bearer and private
and interestingly this was actually put
forward by representative Lynch from
Massachusetts
um so this is on on the Democrat side
and then on the Republican side you have
a number of Champions for private
digital cash who want to create a
sensible regime for stable coins which
are privately issued but if they were
one-to-one redeemable especially if
maybe there was some some actual law
that backed that Redemption power would
would once again be something like a
something as good as a dollar something
that's digital and and trustworthy and
these are there are many folks um
um Congressman McHenry uh who's the
chair of house Financial Services now uh
Congressman emmer who's the the majority
whip in in in the house
um we had a great Senator unfortunately
Senator Toomey who's who's retired uh
was a great uh advocate for uh this
stuff in the Senate
um and and hopefully someone comes up
and fills his his big shoes but and
there's a number of folks um that that I
think are are on board this is again
maybe an area where you could bend the
Horseshoe and find weird but
um you know uh keep keep crypto weird uh
coalitions that both people care about
privacy both people care about American
values maybe we could do something with
a digital Tower I love uh Zach is going
to ask you a final question but I just
want to say I love the idea of rapping
you know and it's kind of jingoistic on
a certain level but I think it's
accurate and it's actually what the
planet needs certainly what America
needs to you know wrap Bitcoin to wrap
privacy to wrap Financial Security in
you know in the American flag because we
as as a nation we have clearly lost a
sense of identity and a sense of purpose
and a sense of of common belief
um and I think what you're talking about
might be a powerful way to get us you
know I I have this theory that we're in
we're trapped in the long 20th century
and we are struggling to maintain these
kind of zombie belief systems these
zombie coalitions these zombie political
parties that no longer speak haven't
spoken to how people actually live for
20 30 maybe 40 years but it's really
hard to kind of you know crack that
shell and just molt and get rid of them
and move into the 21st century but maybe
this rhetorical and ideological angle
will help uh you know reformulate
American politics so that we can get on
with the future rather than having these
idiotic battles with the past
I also appreciate that yeah I appreciate
the the optimism because often there's a
sort of doomerism and cynicism within
both kind of some strains of
libertarianism and also just crypto
World more broadly so I do appreciate
that I and I think that one of the
reasons for the pessimism at the moment
is the what seems to be a concerted
effort to crack down on cryptocurrency
post the FTX meltdown
um we've talked with uh Nick Carter
who's called it operation choke point
2.0 where there seems to be this ongoing
effort to make it harder and harder to
switch in between uh Bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies and cash mostly other
cryptocurrencies actually and uh I
wonder if you are worried about this is
and this is this will be my final
question are you worried about that
effort that do you agree that it's an
ongoing effort are you worried about the
trends as someone who who has a lot on
his plate fighting the government
already and uh do you think that crypto
will prevail some crypto will prevail or
um is it kind of in trouble
so at the end of the day I think this
technology is Unstoppable and
um and I think that's a good thing you
know that might be scary to some people
but I think that's actually very good
especially given the fact that we have
other Technologies like generative AI
that are extraordinarily powerful and
need technological limitations because
government limitations are going to
often be uh incapable of actually
addressing the threat you know the the
best answer to anyone can impersonate
you online convincingly is all right we
need self-sovereign identity and so in
many ways the best answer to threats
posed by generative AI are
cryptocurrencies and blockchains where
people can be Sovereign over their own
identity and their money
um as I said I think it's Unstoppable
but I don't think that means that the
transition to a more decentralized
internet and a more decentralized
financial system will be peaceful
um and just like we saw in the early
days of the internet with people having
SWAT teams break into their houses
because they were running a server
that's happening now and that will
continue to happen now uh and so coin
Center's Mission can really be
understood as harm harm mitigation or
minimization like can we find Common
Ground between policy makers and
technologists such that we don't have
bad laws passed out of ignorance we
don't have people sort of acculturated
in in a policy making environment where
they think that this is all scams and
frauds and God knows our space the
technology space doesn't always make
that job easy actually because there are
a lot of frauds in this space that sort
of they're just naked same old schemes
as always Ponzi schemes or or just now
you uh you can say FTX you don't have to
uh code it
hell I'll call them all out because yeah
make my job hard and at the end of the
day it's just it's just up to us to say
uh do a better job with education
explaining the difference between a
decentralized exchange where people hold
their own money and a centralized
exchange where they're still trusting
some guy with more curly hair than I
have to not you know misspend it and on
the other hand um you know when the
hammer comes down hard in response to
the frauds and the scams and we've
failed to educate to make sure that we
can defend people's constitutional
rights the Constitution is this amazing
forcing function in America of course
policymakers are going to be responsive
to the biggest crisis at the at the
given moment where there is a crisis of
course they're going to reach for blunt
instruments to attack things that are
perceived as real social ills whether
they're Tick Tock or FTX the
Constitution is there to say we need to
take a Long View there are certain
things that transcend the crisis of the
moment and those things are speech and
privacy the first and fourth amendments
and so I'm incredibly privileged to be
in a position where you know some people
will listen to me and I can fight for
those rights
I you know I want to thank you for you
know not just appearing here but the
work that you're doing at coin Center
because like you and I think a lot of
people who remember the 90s certainly
and and were kind of early adopters of
digital culture
um you know there is a sense of
technological
um optimism in the sense that you know
the better Technologies the things that
liberate and decentralize and Empower
people do win out but it you know you
want to shorten the the war period I
mean the the printing press was a
phenomenal technology but it took you
know 400 500 years maybe before
everybody got comfortable with like the
idea that you could you know print Lady
Chatterley's Lover In America and a lot
of people were literally jailed or
burned at the stake for printing the
wrong thing and like if we can shrink
400 years of you know fighting over you
know what we now recognize as a basic
Freedom down to you know five months or
five years or something like that be all
the better we're going to leave it here
uh Peter Von valkenberg of coin Center
thank you so much for talking with us uh
this has been the reason live stream
Zach weismiller thank you so much thank
you we'll see everybody next Thursday
thanks so much